abby shapiro just got in trouble abby
shapiro was not doing anything creepy or
not abby shapiro got in trouble for a
tweet
in which she called out this kind of
thing so abby for those of you who don't
know abby is ben's sister
obviously a friend of ours for many many
years and abby has her own channel
called classically abby where she
advocates for a more traditional normal
kind of lifestyle so she sent out this
tweet
two pictures side by side
one is nancy reagan with her family i
guess at the reagan ran it looks like
it's at the reagan ranch and one is of
madonna who is now in her 60s
dressed up like she's
a much younger woman doing much
nastier things than 60 year old women
should be doing
abby writes from the classically abbey
account this is madonna at 63 this is
nancy reagan at 64. trashy living versus
classy living which version of yourself
do you want to be
and she was pilloried for this the tweet
went viral
molly jong fast who is a left-wing
writer writing in the daily beast said
that abby classically abby and her
brother ben they're just boomers they're
like millennial boomers
if you criticize
madonna a boomer for her boomer
lifestyle you're apparently a boomer and
if you criticize libs for indulging it
you're apparently
a boomer of course the opposite would be
true but but even just on
then the left were attacking nancy
reagan they were pulling up some tabloid
bs biography and saying that nancy
reagan was actually herself promiscuous
back in hollywood which is which is not
true there's no evidence of it
there were two
actresses by the same name nancy
reagan's maiden name is nancy davis
there's another actress named nancy
davis there's no evidence that nancy
reagan the lady who became nancy reagan
was ever promiscuous there is
a fair bit of evidence that the other
nancy davis was perhaps and so anyway
they're just getting that wrong and then
the left is they're making all these
sorts of ugly claims about nancy reagan
but furthermore furthermore
anyone who is claiming that they would
rather be like
madonna
alone on a bed dressed up like a hooker
intentionally dressed she's dressed up
like a hooker to be sexually provocative
in her 60s that that's what you want to
be rather than having your family around
you dressed up like a normal respectable
person on your nice ranch they're lying
to you that's obviously
a lie established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of lord or
lady in scotland just like me
your humble host lord michael knowles
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land and a certificate
established titles is a project based on
an historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lards
or lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you will receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land you can even get a
couple pack for you and your spouse or
loved one of unspecified
distinction you will be able to have
land right next to one another at one
square foot and you will both get to be
called lord and lady you can get this on
your credit card on your plane tickets
you can even put it on your dating
profiles
established titles currently having a
massive holiday sale on top of that sale
you can get an additional 10 off any
purchase you make with discount code
knowles so click the link below or go to
establishtitles.com knowles use promo
code noles to save an extra 10
today if you if you really think you'd
rather be dressed up like a hooker on a
bed alone at age 63 rather than standing
around your nice family with you know
everyone who loves you and you know
dressed normally then either that that
is evidence of a disordered will your
will has been so corrupted maybe by porn
or maybe just by a lot of bad ideas and
a lot of bad behaviors in your life or
it's just a fatal dose of copium you are
lying to yourself and trying to cope
with your own
bad views and decisions and and uh
and way that you have lived your life
but
nobody i don't think anybody who is in
their right mind could look at those two
pictures and actually say no i really no
i really do want to be like madonna no
you don't she looks miserable okay and
nancy reagan looks happy
relatively this is a tough world there's
always problems everybody's got problems
but
everyone wants to end up like the
picture on the right not like the
picture
on the left
i'm so glad you like that clip now
if you want to get all the clips and all
the shows and all the episodes you've
got to
ring the bell and subscribe that way
you'll get notifications and by the way
if you really want to guarantee you get
notifications for the whole show head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast subscribe
maybe leave a five star review if you
like it we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you